Và khi các bạn rửa chào các bạn man kým thì vòng các bạn chỉ đó của chúng ta mới thành
Và các bạn cùng phía nhá một cái thật tám mà mình phải làm mà mình phải đang týt của mình vòng đó
trên công thông tin của bộ
Nếu bạn đang kým mình vòng tài trường
ở bên dưới tại vì là người thật này mất trường của chúng ta đó
nhưng mà không đang ký lình thống thông tin của bộ thì rõ này
các bạn có mẹ không được đủy
nên đây là một cái điều mặt rất nhiều tự bản thý sinh
mà chúng ta bị mặt phải
chúng ta biết ở đây chúng ta đang kým mình vào mẹ tý vị trọng không tình
tự thích trường đó là chúng ta nó
và tụi khi đang ký lình đó như các bạn quên là một thật tám tin trong tụi tình của bộ dựa ở đây là các bạn cũng sẽ bị